voyez des images qui nous ont tous
bouleversés à du reportage de ma
collègue louise despatie présenté au
téléjournal vendredi mais ça nous a fait
penser de vous de se rappeler ensemble
les meilleurs conseils pour éviter des
incendies qui viennent trop souvent
assombrir le temps des fêtes des drames
vraiment qu'ils pourraient être évités
roger gilbert ancien officier du service
dès samedi de montréal est avec moi ce
matin bonjour c'est juste un bonjour
ancien pompier en ses porte parole
également pour nous rappeler les
meilleurs conseils qu envoyer des images
comme celles-là à quoi ça vous fait
penser à quoi ça me fait penser la
période des fêtes on a un repas qu'on
aime beaucoup faire si de la fondue et
quand on fait de la fondue mais soit on
l'a fait
or se dérouleront près de six verres
puis on oublie que c'est dangereux de
remplir le petit récipient avec le
combustible sous le soul a fondu sous le
poêlon et y est chaud on remplit puis la
catastrophe arrive
le feu prend et puis souvent on se
ramasse avec des brûlures et puis il ya
beaucoup de cas par année où des gens se
retrouvent au centre des grands brûlés
parce qu'ils ont été négligents avec le
poids la fondue est aussi le petit foyer
à l'éthanol aussi on a eu dernièrement
quelqu'un qui était gravement brûlé à
cause de ça pour faire attention faut
attendre que le tout soit frais pour
remplir de nouveau et du combustible
donc à ce moment là sinon on change les
petits récipients simplement on a moins
froid qu'on a donc on au surplus
cotillons l'install en dessous puis on
repart le tout mais on fait jamais
remplissage quand le tout échoue parce
que c'est très dangereux et ça peut
arriver tellement rapidement c'est ça
que vous voyez c'est donc des petites
choses qui peuvent faire une grande
différence souvent ce que c'est la
négligence qui peut allumer les
incendies c'est la cause première
c'est vrai oui la négligence et ce qui
fait partie de la vie tout le monde on
oublie souvent plein de trucs au bond le
poil en éthanol on vient de parler de ça
on parle aussi de l'oublier un chaudron
sur la cuisinière on réorganise non on a
une chambre d'un appartement une pièce
pour la période des fêtes pour les
festivités se passer sans brise la
routine mobilisa vous tiennent plus
longtemps ce les meubles sur le long des
plinthes chauffard alors que ça c'est
dangereux et on oublie plein de choses
comme ça durant la défaite on met
beaucoup de bougies donc souvent on va
aller au lit
on oublie de détail les bougies et puis
là ben voilà la catastrophe arrive il
arrive tellement vite c'est 5 fois c'est
incroyable est ce que vous voulez
rappelé également l'importance de
pelleter et devant toutes les sorties de
secours toutes les issues de la maison
oui mais ça c'est important on n'a pas
eu beaucoup de neige encore d'avoir il
faut vraiment dégager les issues parce
qu'il faut sortir si jamais il ya un
début d'incendié
souvent la porte que vous n'avez pas
dégagé va vous empêcher de sortir à
l'extérieur si ce qui fait que mon nom à
des drames puis on a des décès puis dire
le temps des fêtes baisse inévitable les
feu de sapins de noël
ouais il y en a il y en a encore
malheureusement on oublie une vidéo qui
circule actuellement sur facebook qui
demande à la vitesse à laquelle le feu
prend l'intérieur et dans de quelques
secondes le sapin et d'un embrasement
général et puis voilà pile le feu se
répand dans la pièce il faut faire
attention à surfing est ce qu'on doit
faire
justement concernant le sapin naturel si
sapin naturel un fouillis donner de
l'eau et a besoin d'eau à l'occasion et
inde les décorations les lumières dedans
quand on va au lit puis on quitte la
maison on était les lumières et puis
sachez aussi que peu trop près d'une
plage aux femmes parce que ça non plus
font pas bon ménage entre les deux donc
pensé à tous les détails pensez à tous
les détails puis l'autre détail aussi
important d'avoir un bon avertisseurs de
fumée ça c'est bien important parce que
si vous n'avez pas d'avertisseur de
fumée
si votre garantie que si jamais un début
d'incendié lui vous avisez pour sortir
rapidement sinon vous aurez rien pour
vous avisez j'aime ça qu'on le rappelle
ensemble parce que normalement quand on
change là on se voit toujours vous venez
l'émission vous nous dites vous fait pas
seulement vérifier les piles des
détecteurs de fumée vous aller plus loin
vous mais il faut vérifier la pile mais
il faut le nettoyer aussi à l'occasion
faut s'assurer qu'il est bien
positionnée souvent on achète un
avertisseur de fumée puis à l'intérieur
du boîtier
de la boîte il ya des consignes
d'installation les gens lisses passera
c'est comme quand on achète quelque
chose qu'on l'ait pas les instructions
on installe son important comme ça et
puis le montre entre amos un moment
donné que l'avertisseur de fumée mal
positionné qu'est ce qu'on fait on
l'enlève on enlève la paix l'intérieur
il faut pas faire ça il faut s'assurer
que lié bien positionné si vous avez des
doutes
après votre service incendie sont là
pour vous guider puis vous dirigez dans
votre ville
et quand vous êtes de vérifier les piles
vous dit même qu'on doit les changer oui
pleinement oui une fois par année
changer les pièces si on veut pas faire
ça il ya des avertisseurs de fumée qu'il
fonctionne avec une pile au lithium
cette pile là est bonne pour dix ans
donc que vous avez pas besoin de changer
la pile par contre vous devez vérifier
l'avertisseur au moins une fois par mois
avec le petit bouton thèse dessus et le
nettoyer délicatement avec un aspirateur
pour s'assurer que les théories fait son
pop ce truc c'est noté toujours un
plaisir immense merci pour vos banques
ont dû si bojan les doutes mais qui
envoie sur les sites internet de la
cerise incendie ils vont être les
consignes de sécurité deux excellents
mais c'est à vous qu'on peut voir